earlier today i received orders from my
superior i'm being sent to investigate a
mysterious scp located under a warehouse
on the outskirts of london it seems
important as the scp was just discovered
and the overseer council wants a
detailed report on it right away i pull
up outside of the port superior canning
company warehouse it is abandoned and
from the look of it has been for a long
time i enter the building and make my
way to an opening at the far side of the
warehouse i descend the narrow stairwell
where i see a small black door i was
told there was always a guard posted by
the door there was no one here i stop
just outside of the black door and look
up above the door handle is a placard
that says scp foundation department of
abnormalities i'm in the right place but
nothing feels right maybe i should just
turn around and tell my superior i
couldn't find the door i take a deep
breath grab the handle and turn the door
doesn't budge i step back for a moment
and take a breath of relief then i
glance to the side of the door and see
the sliding lock my stomach sinks i move
the metal rod aside and try the door
again this time it swings open i shake
my head and dismay and walk into the
other side of the black door i have now
entered scp-3790
a series of dim emergency lights flicker
on there are four doors on the other
side of the hallway is an elevator
hello i'd say only slightly louder than
a whisper there is no response i walk
along the grated floor the metal rattles
under my boots i can see through the
grating and it appears there are several
floors below me i come to the first door
and examine it all of the doors are
identical they are made up of heavy
metal a sliding panel that covers a
glass viewport and placards that
identify what is in the room all of the
handles to the doors have been broken
off and the doors themselves have been
welded shut it seems that whoever
abandoned the department of
abnormalities wanted to make sure
whatever is in these rooms never got out
as i stare into the room i begin to feel
something well up inside of me i zone
out for a moment when i regain my
bearings my hand has moved itself to the
spot where the door handle once was as
if while i was in my days something
tried to trick me into opening the door
i immediately shove my hands into my
pockets turn and walk back toward the
black door to get out of this place
something is not right here as i
approach the exit the door slams shut i
race over to it and try turning the knob
it will not budge i've been locked in
scp-3790
i begin to panic as my eyes start from
door to door scanning for a way out
there is nowhere to go but deeper into
the department of abnormalities i glance
down to my right and notice something
lying on the ground it's a clipboard i
pick it up and skim through the pages of
the legal pad that is attached to it
most of what is written seems like the
ravings of a madman but on one page
there are some coherent notes it says
think it's about time need to lock down
the other sides before i go take care
there is a list of 10 roman numerals
with either the word locked or unlocked
beside them
7 8
and 10 all remain unlocked i'm not sure
if this is a good or a bad thing but it
seems that whoever was here before me is
now on their way to complete what they
started i tossed the clipboard and
looked down the corridor hoping that a
magical door will appear and let me out
of the department of abnormalities after
several minutes i decide to explore
scp-3790 more thoroughly perhaps there
is another way out on a different level
this gets my hopes up slightly but part
of me believes that this will be where i
spend the rest of my short life i walk
back up to the door where i think i hear
music coming from i wipe the dust and
grime off the placard and read what it
says the name written on it is vivaldi i
slide the panel away from the viewport
and look inside the chamber is
completely empty except for one object
in the far corner of the room a violin
is propped up against the wall in front
of it is a broken bow i squint my eyes
to get a better look at the instrument
it seems normal enough suddenly an
uneasy feeling comes over me like i'm
being watched i whip the panel closed
over the viewport and back away from the
door i turn down the hallway and walk to
the next door the name on the placard
for this room is montezuma's face i'm a
little hesitant to open the panel and
peer inside because of what might be
looking back at me i take a breath to
build a bit of courage and go for it i
slide the panel open and to my relief
all that is on the other side of the
viewport is an empty room with a metal
table in the center on it rests in
ornate wooden chest the chest has been
secured with a large steel padlock i put
my face a little closer to the glass to
try to get a better look at the markings
on the chest i can hear a faint clicking
sound like that of a ticking clock
coming from the room other than that all
is still i shrug and check the next door
to my surprise the next room has had its
placard removed when i peer into the
viewport the room is completely empty
this is strange as this door has also
been welded shut the fourth door in the
corridor has had its placard damaged
making the text on it unreadable i slide
the panel open and look inside there
appears to be nothing there but upon
closer inspection i see that the
concrete walls are covered in claw marks
it looks like whatever was in this
chamber had incredibly sharp talons and
was not happy about being detained on
the floor are pieces of bone that have
had the meat picked clean from them each
room is another mystery but offers no
way out of the department of
abnormalities my only hope is to go
deeper into the facility i push the
button for the elevator the door chimes
and slides open i step inside and look
at the seven buttons on the panel next
to each one is the level number it
corresponds to naturally i'm hesitant to
push any of them but i know i've got to
start somewhere if i'm going to have any
chance of getting out of here i reach
out and press the button for level two
the doors slide shut and the elevator
descends deeper into the depths of the
department of abnormalities the elevator
comes to a stop and the doors slide open
i step out into another corridor it
seems identical to the first one except
there is no black door on the opposite
side of the hallway this worries me a
little but i continue on according to
the placard of the first door of level 2
the room contains a man named ian i
slide the panel open and look through
the viewport in the corner of the room
sits a thin pale man wearing a dirty
straitjacket he is blindfolded and does
not seem to notice me his chest moves
slowly up and down i feel bad for the
man being cooped up in there all alone
but then again i have no idea what ian
is capable of the second room on this
level contains something called the
crying boy when i look into the chamber
i expect to see a young child weeping
instead there appears to be a painting
on an easel in the middle of the room it
has a sheet draped over it so i cannot
see what is on the canvas but from
inside the room i can hear the sobs of a
small child the placard for the third
room indicates that the creatures that
are contained within it are called the
watchers when i look into the chamber i
see three humanoid figures huddled
together they are all staring towards
the far corner with their backs turned
toward me the creatures sway back and
forth slowly it's an unsettling sight to
say the least one that will be difficult
to forget and will definitely haunt my
dreams the fourth door on level two has
no placard when i look inside i see
another dark hallway similar to the one
i'm in i try to force the door open as
it might be a way out but like all the
rest it has been welded shut i kick the
metal door hoping and wishfully thinking
it will make an impact but instead i
instantly regret my decision i
contemplate my extreme lack of karate
skills as i limp back to the elevator
and defeat i descend to the third level
room one on level three contains
something called the infinite cold when
i look into the chamber i can see that
the floor is covered with a thin layer
of ice what is odd is that the interior
of the room seems to go on forever in
all directions it even appears to extend
to the room next to it but when i look
into the viewport to the second room
there is a solid wall between the
infinite cold and the empty pedestal in
room two i checked the placard for the
second room and find that it is called
sorrow it looks like there was one
something on top of the pedestal but the
four finger marks left in the dust that
now covers it indicates the object had
been moved recently the third room is
named world without man unsurprisingly
the chamber is completely empty the
fourth room on this level is labeled
adam's hatred this does not seem like
something i want to see but i slide the
panel away from the viewport and glance
in anyway in the back of the room is a
large black mass slowly oscillating in
mid-air i feel anger begin to fill me
the rage of this creature is palpable
it's being transferred from the black
mass to me scared of what it or i might
do i run back to the elevator and hit
the button for level four on the placard
of the first room on level four are the
words the morning star all that is in
the chamber is a rusted sword hanging
from the wall however as i move my face
closer to the window to get a better
look the temperature starts to rise it
feels like the fires of hell are just on
the other side of this door the placard
for the next room is labeled wormwood
but when i open the panel to peer inside
there is something obstructing my view i
don't spend much time here and move on
to the next the placard on door 3 names
this anomaly as harmonia's necklace
within the chamber a golden chain hangs
from a post against the back wall a
single candle burns just beneath the
necklace illuminating the space around
it when i look closer at the candle i
realize the chamber has no floor the
light seems to be floating among
infinite darkness the fourth chamber on
this level has no placard when i look
inside the room is unlit all i feel is a
sense of dread a feeling that follows me
all the way back to the elevator i
descend to level 5. the first door is
labeled as the heart of man inside is a
human heart suspended in mid-air by a
wire hanging from the ceiling i look
closer and to my horror i see the heart
is still beating the entire room starts
to distort my own heart aches i run down
the hallway to the second door the
placard for this room has been pried off
the word hello has been scratched into
the metal where the label once was when
i try to slide the panel over to look
into the room i find that just like the
door itself the panel has also been
welded shut whatever is on the other
side of this door must truly be terrible
the third door contains something called
channel 55. in the room there is a small
crt television set under a dark cloth i
can see the light from the tv shining
through the sheet but cannot make out
the image on the screen the fourth door
of floor 5 has a placard with the words
living nightmare printed on it i pause
for a moment to think if i really want
to see what is inside this room i figure
i've come this far and maybe it's just a
trick to keep me from finding the exit i
slowly slide the panel away from the
viewport it makes a sound like a creaky
door opening in a haunted house in the
room there is a bed resting on a metal
frame someone appears to be lying on the
bed with a sheet pulled over their head
creepy i think i walk back to the
elevator and cannot help but feel i'm
about to reach something terrifyingly
significant in my journey one way or
another whatever is on the next two
floors will seal my fate i get off on
level six it looks identical to all the
previous floors the first room contains
something called mr silence resting on
the back chamber wall is a tall wooden
box it has been painted black with a
purple w adorning the front of it i hold
my breath for a moment it's so quiet
that the silence hurts my ears the
second room contains the dead man's
chair in the corner of the chamber is a
wooden seat there's no one sitting on it
but as i look at the shadow against the
wall there is clearly a figure seated
there i glanced back at the wooden chair
but it is still empty and upon a second
look at the shadow the figure is gone
the placard on the third door reads
let's see when i slide open the viewport
it is covered in ice i can't see
completely through the ice but from what
i can make out there seems to be a dark
shape standing in the middle of the room
the fourth door on level six contains
apollyon's crown there are scratch marks
all across the metal door it looks as if
something was trying to get into the
room instead of out of it in the chamber
itself is a silver lock box resting on a
table whatever is inside must be very
important to someone i enter the
elevator and press the button for level
seven the door slides shut and the
elevator begins to descend to the bottom
level i know that if there is no way out
on this floor i will be trapped like all
the other objects in the department of
abnormalities the bell chimes indicating
i've reached what i hope is my way out
of here the doors slide open i take a
few steps out into a corridor that looks
like all the rest i turn and gaze into
the first room on the floor instantly
terror fills every centimeter of space
in my core it feels as if my heart stops
frozen in fear for a moment i try to
scream but nothing escapes i come to my
senses and i'm able to use my legs again
i run back to the elevator and hit the
button for the first floor as the
elevator ascends back to where i began
this nightmarish tour my body trembles
more and more as soon as the elevator
chimes at level 1 without hesitation and
with my shaking hands and nimble fingers
i immediately rip open the button panel
and tear out the wires connected to
level seven no one should ever have to
see what is that far down in the
department of abnormalities and now no
one ever will now watch
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality or check out 25
most frightening scp